[Música]
aquí comienza a ella soy de france24
serena williams se retira a sus 40 años
en las 23 veces campeona de torneos
grand slam individuales y 14 en dobles
se dijo que planea ponerle fin a esta
carrera que tantos triunfos le ha dado y
que redefinido el deporte reservado
previamente para personas caucásicas y
de clase media-alta williams describió
sus planes de jubilación en la revista
vogue vamos a conversar sobre el tema
que aquí les contamos en el siguiente
informe de luís méndez
la cuenta regresiva ha comenzado
escribió la tenista en una columna para
la revista vogue no lo confirma pero lo
insinúa que su último gran slam podría
ser el próximo abierto de eeuu
así lo anunció cuando le preguntaron
sobre su futuro en una rueda de prensa
en toronto
amo jugar es increíble pero sabes no
puedo hacer esto por siempre aquí en
tres a un mes de cumplir 41 años y con
23 títulos individuales de grand slams
williams no descarta uno más su historia
incluye a su hermana venus siete veces
ganadora de grand slam y a menudo
oponente de serena juntas han ganado 14
títulos de dobles en grandes torneos
desde los 4 años las hermanas fueron
educadas en casa y entrenadas por su
padre y triste que ganó su primer grand
slam a los 17 años es aclamada como una
de las mejores jugadoras de todos los
tiempos para serena no cuenta competir
solo ganar
me encantan los desafíos me encanta
alzar trofeos supongo que si alguna vez
siento que no puedo hacer eso tal vez no
juegue más framework una actitud que le
ha llevado a ganar los principales
cuatro torneos en un mismo a menudo ha
denunciado el racismo y la misoginia en
el tenis williams ha dominado un juego
asociado por mucho tiempo con blancos de
clase media y alta o como dijo wimbledon
en un tuit algunos juegan el deporte
otros lo cambian en 2017 cuando anunció
su embarazo se tomó una breve licencia
por maternidad pero antes ganó el
abierto de australia con dos meses de
embarazo en poco tiempo volvería al 'top
ten' sin embargo ahora quiere ser madre
nuevamente aunque no desea estar
embarazada como atleta profesional sus
palabras resonaron en muchos ella nunca
quiso elegir entre el tenis y su familia
y no tendría que hacerlo si fuera un
hombre pero como ella explicó el trabajo
de expandir una familia así lo obliga
la conversación no es sobre esta noticia
trascendental para el tenis y para las
mujeres es con el mar esa periodista de
deportes de france 24 el mar gracias y
vamos a comenzar hablando de este
artículo de la revista vogue que lo
describe muy bien serena williams habla
en primera persona de esa necesidad casi
biológica de tener que elegir entre
agrandar su familia o darse unos años
más en la cancha de tenis es un buen
momento para retirarse o para
evolucionar como ella misma lo describe
digamos que es el momento en el que más
bien muy pocas tenistas llegan hasta una
edad tan avanzada jugando bien sea
porque tienen reciben ese llamado del
reloj biológico bien sea porque ya no se
consideran suficientemente competitivas
por por diversas razones ella ha tenido
una carrera sumamente prolongada ha
alcanzado una etapa
tremendamente longeva y al mismo tiempo
desde mucho antes de que su carrera
tenística despegará este cultivo otros
intereses como el diseño de sus propios
uniformes que la llevó a e incursionar
en el diseño de modas y en negocios y
aprender a hacer negocios más allá del
tenis entonces creo que ella mismo había
venido pavimentando ese camino para
poder dar este salto un camino en el que
además no ha sido alcanzada por ningún
hombre al menos siendo ganadora de
competencias de grand slam individuales
y además ella hace esta crítica a los
desafíos que tiene ser mujer en una
cultura deportiva en la que perdemos
vuelo y sacrificamos siempre las mujeres
nuestras carreras cuando nos llega el
momento de la maternidad sacrificios que
los colegas masculinos no tienen que
confrontar usted ve posibilidades de que
esa realidad mejore gracias a figuras
como serena williams que lo denuncian y
bueno que a pesar de todo pues nos
demuestran esta grandeza en el deporte
yo pienso que sí mujeres como serena
williams lo han puesto de manifiesto lo
han puesto de relieve la necesidad de
poder conjugar esas dos facetas de la
mujer como usted decía no hay ningún
atleta masculino que haya alcanzado lo
que ella logró 23 grande en individuales
es más de lo que tiene por ejemplo
rafael nadal que tiene 22 o novak
djokovic que tiene 21 o el gran roger
federer que tiene 20 hay mujeres aparte
de harina que están luchando para lograr
congeniar o conciliar esas dos facetas
dentro del deporte y podemos mencionar
el caso de la atleta allyson felix es la
más laureada de la historia en el
atletismo estadounidense tanto en
mundiales como en juegos olímpicos
allyson felix cuando quedó embarazada de
su hija perdió 75% en su contrato de
patrocinio con like la empresa se lo
retiró por haber quedado embarazada y
ella simplemente rompió ese contrato y
empezó a como les recomendó su hermano
en esta oportunidad usa tu voz ella
comenzó a usar su voz para denunciar que
había sufrido esta forma de
discriminación y hoy en día nike ha
cambiado su política ya sin allyson
felix ha cambiado la política y cubre
completamente tanto premios como bonos
como pagos de patrocinio los 18 meses
alrededor de todo el proceso de embarazo
durante y después y además se haya
logrado allyson felix conseguir que haya
un servicio de babysitter que en los
campeonatos mundiales que tanto jueces
como entrenadores como atletas puedan
viajar con sus hijos y tenerlos cuidados
mientras se dedican a sus carreras son
grandísimas ganancias en un mundo que
discrimina altísimamente a las mujeres
que juegan las mismas disciplinas que
con hombres pues no pasaría eso no
sucede en estos casos de discriminación
pero vamos a hablar un poco más acerca
de lo que es ser mujer de lo que implica
nuestra fisionomía nuestra fisiología
para pararnos en una cancha para
practicar cualquier disciplina deportiva
entonces en el caso de serena williams
la maternidad el posparto la depresión
postparto y a pesar de todo eso ella ha
continuado jugando y ha continuado
ganando ganó un gran slam en australia
estando embarazada y además pues como
toda mujer durante gran parte de su vida
pues ha tenido que afrontar la
menstruación cada mes que estos cambios
de ciclos hormonales que les juegan a
favor o en contra a los deportistas no
fue el caso de zerlina porque ella
siempre fue tu bola la vigilancia muy
cercana de su padre pero además a esos
desafíos a los que usted se refiere está
el tema del acoso que del que muchas
veces son digamos de manera prevalente
víctima más las mujeres que los hombres
entonces son claro muchos desafíos a los
que tienen que enfrentarse
e incluso abusos relacionados no
solamente con el tema sexual y con la
diferencia de figuras de poder entre un
entrenador y un atleta o entre un
dirigente y un atleta sino incluso de
estrategias competitivas en la antigua
alemania socialista que se caracterizó
por unas violaciones terribles de
derechos humanos en lo que tiene que ver
con el uso del dopaje se acostumbraba
que los entrenadores embarazaran a sus
atletas en los momentos previos a
competir para que tuvieran digamos un
impulso por la cantidad de hormonas y
luego las obligaban a abortar o sea esos
son el tipo de desafíos a los que han
tenido que enfrentarse a las mujeres en
el deporte y que ha venido a poner de
relieve una figura como sobrina william
y que vienen a cambiar hablemos más de
estas luchas serena williams como una
figura que cambió el deporte gracias a
su influencia contra la discriminación
de género y contra la idea de percepción
racial si para empezar con el tema de la
percepción racial es muy importante es
citar un ejemplo que fue el boicot a
indian wells indian wells es un torneo
muy importante que se juega en palm
springs en california es considerado
como el quinto gran slam porque es un
torneo que se extiende a lo largo de dos
semanas o sea que tiene cuadro muchísimo
más grandes que los torneos que
normalmente se inician los lunes o los
martes y terminan el domingo y
históricamente es un torneo sumamente
importante en 2001 servida y vino su
hermana tenían que medirse en la
semifinal vinos sufrió una molestia
durante los entrenamientos y no notificó
con tiempo a la organización que no iba
a competir sino al momento de salir a la
cancha dijo no puedo jugar eso ocasionó
una serie de abucheos que ya comenzaron
con tinte racial al momento de jugarla
se orina incluso la rusa elena
deméntieva que se enfrentaba en esa
semifinal que perdió en cuartos de final
con vinos hizo un comentario totalmente
desafortunado cuando le preguntaron
quién quieres que gane en la semifinal
se orina ovinos y ella dijo el que diga
richter refiriéndose al padre de ambas
atletas y richard fue el objeto de
abucheos durante toda la final de sorina
contra kim clijsters le gritaban cosas
como no queremos negros aquí y a partir
de ese momento su vida hizo un boicot de
14 años y vino uno de 16 al torneo de
indian wells cuando regresaron en 2018
coincidiendo ambas hermanas el aplauso
fue estruendoso se habían ganado su
puesto creo que eso es muy importante
comentarlo y sobre el tema de género
sobrinas y una de las grandes luchadoras
por uno de los objetivos en los que el
tenis es pionero a nivel mundial que es
la igualdad salarial la igualdad de
premios entre atletas masculinos y
femeninos ella fue una gran luchadora
para conseguir esa esa igualdad
hoy en día los grand slam premian igual
a hombres y mujeres tal vez haya torneos
donde haya diferencia pero los grandes
torneos del calendario no hacen
diferencia entre hombres y mujeres se
nos acaba el tiempo de omer pero la
última pregunta y muy rápidamente
primero esta venus williams después esta
serena williams como pioneros en el
deporte como pioneras en el mundo de las
atletas femeninas y nos dejan un legado
claro que si se brinda uno habla mucho
de ese orina por por digamos el volumen
de cantidad de premios o sea se dice
fácil pero son 39 grand slams los 23
individuales 14 en dobles femeninos con
vinos y 2 en dobles mixtos con max mirny
pero se brinda vinos fue también una
gran pionera fue la primera mujer
afroamericana que ganó wimbledon por
ejemplo hasta ese momento solamente un
hombre de color artur age en 1970 y 75
había ganado este torneo en 2000 ganó
vinos luego sobrina ganaría siete veces
el torneo de wimbledon pero además vinos
fue la primera mujer afroamericana que
fue número uno del mundo y como lo
confiesa la propia se orina en ese
artículo en la revista vogue ha sido una
gran inspiración y una garra una voz
guía a lo largo de su carrera y aquí
lamentablemente sólo alcanzamos a
delinear lo que ha sido la vida la
carrera la obra de serena williams de
todas maneras vale la pena recordarles y
recomendarles a nuestros televidentes
también que se den una leída a ese
artículo para entender un poco más sobre
los desafíos que implica ser hoy una
mujer en el deporte y aún no diciendo
una mujer como serena williams es más
gracias a usted por estar con nosotros
un placer haber estado acá hablando de
una figura de relieve como esta atleta y
a nuestros televidentes como siempre
gracias y nos vemos próximamente en
ellas hoy sigan en france 24
[Música]